risotto is such a beloved dish but it
can come off as daunting and complicated
if you don't follow a few important
rules we're gonna break down the steps
it takes to make an absolutely perfect
risotto
[Music]
risotto is traditionally made with
arborio rice which is a type of short
grain rice it has a high starch content
which allows it to become creamier once
cooked you can use other types of rice
or grains like long grain rice farro or
barley but we'd recommend sticking with
arborio there's no hard and fast line
when it comes to achieving the ideal
consistency however a good rule of thumb
is for every one cup of rice use four to
six cups of stock we're using chicken
stock but you can use the stock of your
choice or even hot water in a pinch
we're going to bring the stock to a boil
over high heat if you add cold stock to
your rice it won't cook through or
achieve that ideal creamy texture as our
stock comes to a boil we need to select
the right pot for the risotto make sure
to use a tall pot as you continuously
add stock the rice will double in size
and if your pot is too small it could
overflow once the stock is boiling
reduce the heat to a simmer or just keep
it close by the important thing is that
the stock stays warm
bring your risotto pot to the stove and
reduce the heat to medium
now add your oil to the pan
once the oil is hot it's time to add
your allium of choice we're going with
shallots if you don't want to use
shallots you can use other alliums like
onions scallions or garlic whichever you
prefer you're going to cook the shallots
until they're translucent
at this point add the mushrooms and
butter cooking down until soft and
tender this is going to take a little
while so be patient that's really the
theme of this dish but if you don't like
mushrooms you can skip the step and go
straight to adding the rice once your
mushrooms have cooked down add the
garlic thyme
salt and pepper again this is just for
an extra boost of flavor but you can
experiment with the seasonings of your
choice
now it's time to add the rice
stir the rice until it's fully coated
with mushroom mixture you want to toast
the rice but not burn it this will take
a minute or two next add a splash of
wine this adds a boost of acidity to the
dish if you don't want to use alcohol
you can swap it for lemon juice when the
wine is cooked off that's the sign it's
time to start adding the stock word to
the wise patience really is virtue when
it comes to making risotto you want to
add just enough stock to cover the rice
stirring fairly constantly until it's
absorbed don't try to rush the process
by adding more stock this won't allow
the rice to cook evenly and you'll end
up with a soupy mess continue to add the
stock bit by bit until the rice is al
dente which takes about 15 to 20 minutes
you'll know it's done when the rice has
just a bit of firmness left in it and
the texture is creamy if you can pull
the spoon through the risotto and it
slowly oozes back in place you're done
for extra creaminess and flavor add some
grated parmesan and stir to combine and
that's it you're done
risotto really isn't that complicated
there's a lot of room for
experimentation and customization as
long as you remember to abide by the
basic principles take your time be
patient follow the rules and you'll be a
risotto master in no time
so i love it it's rice is my favorite
thing it's it is great rice is my
favorite thing in the world and risotto
is just like
fancy rice
[Music]
you